on July 5th this week marks 75 years of
a service The New National Health
Service starts for so long treasured by
so many hospitals and specialist
Services medicines drugs and appliances
but today the NHS under strain not seen
before
putting huge pressure on a government
that has promised progress the health
secretary clear change in adaptation is
necessary I think the NHS will need to
evolve much more onto prevention rather
than simply looking at treatment part of
that Evolution I think will be much more
focused on prevention and treating
conditions early the ongoing covert
inquiry looking at exactly that how to
prepare and to prevent but the nhs's
problems began long before the pandemic
no one is saying there weren't any
challenges before the pandemic indeed
why the then prime minister prime
minister May brought forward a long-term
plan you acknowledge that between 2010
and up to Theresa May being prime
minister targets were missed that a
long-term plan comes in then we have the
pandemic targets amidst another
long-term plan comes in a e for our
targets were last met in 2015 Cancer
Care targets last night in 2015
do you see the point I'm making here yes
and the point I'm making is things like
the the four hour only Target in Wales
hasn't been met since 2009 so that makes
it okay because well your charge was
this is down to well you're the
government running the NHS England which
serves millions and millions of us the
health secretary being political taking
aim at the labor-run Welsh service and
blaming the impact of covid but at no
point have you acknowledged uh that
funding Cuts hit waiting lists up to
2020 and that has been exacerbated by
the pandemic think people who use the
NHS feel it and then they feel that
you're not acknowledging their truth
there were pressure on waiting times
going into the pandemic because we have
an older population
we're investing in our Workforce in our
NHS estate in the latest technology that
is how we build a sustainable NHS for
the future so keep the faith as your
message to the public yes
a country and its communities who have
for so long kept the faith through a
pandemic and it's aftermath an NHS never
more loved and never more under threat
Beth Rigby Sky News Westminster